also new at noon today Las Vegas Raiders  wide receiver Devonte Adams faces a  misdemeanor assault charge it comes from  this incident we've now seen several  times after the Raiders loss in Kansas  City Monday night Adams as you can see  shoves a photographer to the ground as  he heads to the locker room court  documents allege that victim that man  suffered Whiplash and a headache  yesterday Raiders head coach Josh  McDaniels addressed the incident  I know what happened and those kind of  things I've spoken to Devonte I mean I  support Devonte wholeheartedly as a  human being as a person he's a great guy  I know that was an unfortunate situation  we obviously don't want any of our guys  to be doing anything like that he knows  that he's very well aware of that  again Adam's now facing that misdemeanor  assault charge in Kansas City Adams did  Apologize after the incident as for the  Raiders they're on a bye week the NFL is  investigating the incident and Adams  could face a penalty